es bleibt dabei auch in dieser woche
konnte sich unsere groko in berlin
wieder nicht auf eine menschenwürdige
grundrente einigen aus
wahlkampftaktischen gründen erbärmlich
für alle beteiligten
ich sehe im grunde nur noch eine
schnittmenge in dieser koalition wölfe
erschießen ja das ist glaube ich das
einzige worauf sich noch einigen können
unsere umwelt ministerin svenja schulze
hat am mittwoch einen neuen
gesetzentwurf ins kabinett gebracht der
die sogenannte entnahme von problem
wölfen deutlich erleichtert zwei wochen
nur zwei wochen nachdem sie uns einen
vom artenschutz erzählt hat in diesem
sinne herzlich willkommen zu wild und
hund tv
wild und hund tv mit abdel karim
waidmannsheil freunde
es bleibt dabei der wolf macht angst
kein wunder wir sehen schon fünfjährigen
kindern geschichten wo einem wolf
lebendig der bauch aufgeschlitzt wird
weil er immer gefressen hat und das ist
das happy end
was ist denn mit unserer ohne die wird
auch bald gefressen schlaf jetzt sogar
in der eifel haben wir zwölf ist dass
möglicherweise der erste wolf in unserer
region
na ja ich sag mal so ein hamster ist das
nicht aber leute ganz ehrlich jeder
sieht bedrohlich aus wenn er im dunkeln
in eine fotofalle getappt hier das bild
hat ein freund von mir gemacht ich weiß
genau wie der wolf sich fühlt immer
liegen die bahnsteige sehen viele ältere
damen die schlaufe ihrer handtasche
innerhalb von acht sekunden dreimal um
ihren arm dinge naja wenn man den leuten
angst macht sei es als wolf oder als
marokkaner darf man sich also nicht
wundern
wir wollen für eine wurst freie zone
sorgen
in ganz brandenburg am besten dort wo
beide tiere und menschen leben sollte
der wolf sich zurückziehen und wenn er
das nicht alleine lernt dann müssen wir
ihnen dabei unterstützen
das ist die schönste art zu sagen wie
bringen wir euch alle
natürlich müssen nutztiere geschützt
werden schon allein weil wir menschen
die ja essen wollen deswegen erleichtert
die gruppe jetzt die sogenannte entnahme
von wölfen zudem sollen solche in einem
rudel auch dann geschossen werden dürfen
wenn nicht klar ist welches tier
gerissen hat wer oder was das schwein
nach neuem gesetz könnte man zur not
sogar das ganze rudel abknallen anfang
des jahres hat in der nähe von tübingen
110 schafe gerissen
da sagt doch auch keiner kommen lasst
uns mal ob sicher alle golden retriever
weg polen den wies dann traue ich nicht
die chance einen lebenden volt in
deutschland auch mit zu gesicht zu
bekommen ist gleich null
wo sollen die ganze hysterie denn noch
hinführen müssen sich bald alle sorgen
machen die auch nur irgendwie latent
bedrohlich aussehen
scheiße geld und ruhm stifung für
weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's hier raus
scheiße